you
so I'm at the blue streak hot spring
right now tucked away just south of
Yosemite and I was walking around out
here and I thought it might be a good
time to talk about Pope you cuz i was
thinkin about coaching um cope view is a
really hard concept understand I Tito
and and really hard concept to explain
to other people what it means and if you
look at different styles of IQ dope
they'll use the word cult few slightly
differently so so my interpretation of
coke cube the way I understand work
doesn't really come from like a
dictionary explanation right I'm sure
I've looked it up several different
times and try to break down the kanji
and kind understand what they mean but
my understanding culture comes from
seeing it used in different I Tito
styles and kind of trying to come to the
terms with what the words describing
using different situations so I'm
confuse an old word also right so if you
ask contemporary Japanese speakers about
the word coke view most of them will say
like I don't know what that word is or
that's a weird old word or that words
only using martial arts you know you
hear this kind of stuff a lot because
it's not used all that much um so what
does coke do you mean cohf you literally
means breath and to in order to
understand how it's used in I to do you
cut out and understand the qualities of
breath and what breath is so if you
start to understand those qualities you
can kind of get a handle on what it is
in and how the word coke you can be used
in so many different places I mean the
same thing so first you gotta contention
what is breath so breath is a few things
breath is natural it's relaxed ideally
it happens without a lot of stress it
extends out of the body when I blow out
and it also takes things into the body
pulls things in right so it does it has
both these qualities of bringing
something into me and and sending
something away from me it has a kind of
connotation of calmness
an awareness relaxation so so
understanding these qualities is is
understanding what it's being pointed to
in different I kido styles so for
example in English if someone were to
come in and they were real freaked out
you know something bad happened they got
in a car accident coming in look open I
got the cards in it was crazy stuff just
happen oh my god oh my god right you
would say stop take a breath you know
relax take a breath and and that's the
same ideas as in quick view right which
is to be centered and aware and alert
and to stop and focus on your breathing
right when you start to focus on your
breathing you're pulling in the world
right so you're bringing everything into
you everything's becoming coming into
your awareness so that's a part of
Pocoyo just relaxing enough so that you
can bring things into you and when
you're when you seem coke to use in
Copiah musubi and watch the OS and
zhongshan the the four steps of I key
that's what it's referring to is this
kind of a being able to calm down center
yourself and be aware of everything or
to be completely aware of you and and be
able to be ready to take in other things
from from the rest of the world coke q
also means naturalness rights or
something done in a natural way so when
you hear a coke you nage a lot of times
this is what we're talking about a throw
that happens in a natural way and so if
you look at psycho sensei's work he's a
lot of times calling many different
throws that technically you look very
different the forms very different or
excusing different ways he's calling
them all copine on gays and why because
they're all done in this natural manner
right so its naturalness is also a
quality of Pope view it's something that
naturally and also when you see a pope
30 crew right so and forgive my bad
things pronunciation but a cochlear
okies breath power right and so it's not
saying the power of breathing it's
saying a natural power that's not
stressed and does it take it a lot of
strain it's not difficult it's as
natural as breathing right the power is
very natural because you're using your
body in the correct manner rights you're
using the body correctly and this is
natural way of using it so it's not
stressed out like breathing right so it
went here to work hope to you it's
referring to something that's natural
and not stressed out something that
you're taking in and also something that
you're you're sending out right sending
away from your extension is hope you
write your skin hope you out outside of
yourself right so Pope your hole to
extend in the breadth of direction I
could send something out from you um so
it's difficult as it is to understand
what Cole key means directly if you look
at the qualities of breath and and like
you know I speak English so in English
language this is used all the time also
right Wars talk to you know calm down
relax focus on your breathing take a
breath you know these things are the
same kind of qualities are being
expressed when the word hope' view is
being used in a night kiddo so I hope
this kind of helps clarify some things
cookies are a really interesting subject
to begin to study and being up here in
nature really reminds me of a cookie so
it's poor Kofi Oh a little more and I
hope this helps maybe give you a little
more of a grasp of what cook you might
mean in idea i'm chris hein and i'm just
south of yosemite have a good day
you